[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et le corral
[Musique]
l'école et il sait qu'il avait
pas de fumée en direct primitif
Je suis content de moi et il m'a un peu
j'aime tout chez superman
musique et je suis musicien et chanteur
en 2002 où l'on parle de culpabilité démissionnaire
de mes médias
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Que cherchent-ils
une erreur de voix de mon titre économique et
il m'a dit non
[Musique]
les limites je ne dis jamais résignation
cortizo à la recherche d'un bébé de mission à traverser
par Reuters votes exprimés
sans doute personne
[Musique]
ma bouche j'ai démissionné tout ce que je cherche doyen
De Cali
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sors de la crise
[Musique]
démissionner sous cette limite
dis-moi
ma vie
[Musique]